hey Conan O'Brien here welcome to Conan
O'Brien needs a friend sitting here with
my gang uh talking yeah we're talking uh
Sana Matt we are talking so we are we're
we're game yeah we are a gang you're my
Posse ride or die in my group uh
die I'm excited we have a terrific
program today I believe is it okay to
call it a program I know we've discussed
this before it's the program yeah old
habits die hard they really do I think
you just yeah I just like that we're a
gang do you think we're intimidating yes
I know very intimidating I think you're
intimidating to people I think he's
intimidating yeah like as a person but
you know because you're you are who you
are I think you can sometimes be very
intimidating to like people on the
street well also I'm a I'm a I'm a tall
drink of water but you're like a skinny
tall you know yeah but well muscled uh
chiseled and I was intimidated the first
time I met you what no you weren't yes I
was really sure I came in the room you
were kind of a wise ass I don't remember
you being I don't remember being a wiser
you really weren't you were a nice guy I
was intimidated too well I'm glad I got
it very quick
he'll say that I think there are known
people obviously who's uh
who's their Persona is intimidating and
so I don't think they get uh approached
that much and I I I'm quite certain that
I have one of the least intimidating
personas of any known person because
people aren't afraid to come up you know
what I mean and then if you're you look
at people like a Robert De Niro or a
Sean Penn I think movie people are
different because you see them blown up
on a big screen yeah but you've seen
those people violent yeah like uh you
know you're a funny guy well thank you I
didn't think you enjoyed my my humor oh
thank you I don't know if I enjoy it
okay but you say technically I'm in the
category of funny guy you're in the
category of a funny guy I think that
there's a difference between like you
know bad boy
yeah I'm a bad boy now I'm gonna get in
my truck made of mud
just the wheels are just sloshing off on
the sides falling apart you get two feet
didn't get as far in my mud truck as I
thought I would why did I use this for a
bank robbery
no so uh yeah I do think that uh I I I
don't think I'm an intimidating presence
so I don't know I think you are kind of
but I think you're I don't know
what an interesting conversation
[Applause]
you ever see uh Sonia when she was in
the debate society and I just think
we find in favor
it'd be great if you just use that you
argued in front of the Supreme Court
but wait a minute so you think a woman's
right to privacy defend that well yeah
[Laughter]
yeah I think it's effective It's very
effective it gets the job done everyone
I'm very excited about our guest today
okay mirror yeah I am I am I like this
fellow he's a fine fellow he's a chap
I'm not gonna I don't know
who you're doing and who you're gonna
intro right now I know you do it's you
know what it is stunning
how little you prepare yeah and how
little you know and you know what it's
absolutely true do you guys prepare oh
yeah we write everything this is all
scripted yeah yeah oh no we work very
very hard I feel like sometimes you guys
have meetings and you leave me out of it
I really do of course we're trying to
get stuff done
today's episode guest is yeah do you
have any idea who it could be uh not him
we already did it oh I know who it is
who it's Penn Badgley right because you
you've made a joke right before yes I
used to say because I love just being
stupid for no reason so
um I
it's whenever a Penn badgley's name
comes up uh around here it was because
we booked him and we know that he's
coming on someone said yeah and then
you're going to talk to Penn Badgley and
I'll say more like badge penley and I
kept doing that over and over and over
again
so much so that my kids and I were
watching
um an old Gossip Girl because we do
watch those they're really fun of the
original from the 2000s and someone
um uh I forgot I S I did that joke so
many times yeah you know Penn Badgley
more like badge penley I did it so many
times that I subconsciously thought that
was his name and then I did the same
thing and so my kids said I went yeah
more like pen Badgley and they were like
oh my God you just said his name
correctly because you thought you were
doing a bid but you're only undoing the
stupid bit you've done 50 times I do
that all the time spoonerizing and you
know your name spoonerized is bonan oh
crying yeah of course there's a name for
doing that that's what my parents
intended that's how you working yes okay
okay back off back off back off that's
my mother you're I don't go after
Winifred who's Winifred I don't know who
you're talking about uh well anyway your
get Morley yeah and you're
uhesion
what are you doing now
I don't know I'm a creep my name is bone
and no crying and you're like shocked
that I went in a creepy Direction I
didn't think I'd I never thought I'd get
that from bonan I never thought Mona
would receive that kind of response I
like that when I see the Mona Lisa at
the Louvre I'm like
wait you're like turned on by it yeah
very erotic name here we go my guest
today by her specifically sorry no no no
okay
[Laughter]